[Music]
hey guys I know I'm a little late
actually more late than usual and late
to the second time I actually was
supposed to start streaming but there
was a maintenance patch today for
destiny too and with that they brought
back the faction rally which we are
gonna check out right now I know a lot
of y'all don't necessarily maybe like
destiny as much anymore but faction
rallies are pretty fun time and the
ornaments are part of that this time
around and the new monarchy ornaments
are probably by far one of the coolest
guest sets of armor that you can get sad
part for me is I don't have the new
monarchy gloves so I'm gonna have to be
farming that also I don't know what the
best way to farm coins is anymore now
that we got a new update so we'll have
to see what the best way to farm those
coins are but I'm sure some of the
traditional ways to getting them will be
good I'm heading to the tower now so you
can see how to get some of those coins I
also have so many 3:35 helmets but hello
and thank you for all y'all that are
tuning in appreciate it
we stream every day at 11 a.m. was
really actually hoping that Dragonball
Fighters beta was gonna get extended but
it did not unfortunately I am joining
new monarchy for sure I don't I actually
like future war cult armor and shader
this time around actually the same armor
but the new monarchy stuff just looks
too good too good it looks way too good
let me see if I can preview that
ornament for you oh wait the Helms
actually probably even not even the best
piece to preview it's like the chest the
gloves and the boots they have this
regal ass lying [ __ ] on it
damn it so let's see we got a create
orbs of light what else do we have to do
for these the the ornament unlocks don't
seem too terrible
see you got to get super kills in the e
DZ so yeah not too terrible will go new
monarchy first because you know good
stuff I wouldn't say that only GameSpot
and IGN are still playing destiny I
realize there's been a huge drop-off and
even for me I don't play it as much as I
normally do but I usually come back to
do milestones once a week I raid once a
week with my buddies that's still kind
of fun slowly kind of not becoming this
one just because we've been doing it for
so long but you know faction rallies a
cool time to kind of come back I
definitely want to get all the armor and
the ornaments set for new monarchy
hundred percent of actioning up with you
had a oh my boy seems like it's an auto
rifle for the winners group here
looks like there's faction LEDs easy for
this let's see if I show you that this
is the chest hopefully so that looks
pretty cool shoulders also pretty cools
got the Lions stuff on the on the sides
same with the kneepads and the and also
the like the sash that was pretty sick
so for me like I don't know I I want to
get that now I know that's not for
everyone it's it's definitely vanity I
totally get it I totally get it guys
it's tough I've been trying to defend
the game for a while and it's been
harder and harder to defend the game so
let me go show you guys some of the dead
orbit and the new marquee stuff just so
I know normally I'm a dead orbit guy but
the ornaments aren't as good for them so
gotta go need more Riki this time around
for sure
I'm sure destiny 2 is gonna get a lot
better
I wouldn't say next DLC I bet you come
the yearly anniversary type thing
they're probably a bigger expansion
that'll be better now
yeah we can go into the arguments of
like it should already be good blah blah
blah but I'm not going to get into that
cuz obvious reasons but action rally is
back see what all actions eNOS
so here's her auto rifle sorry I didn't
preview the new monarchy 1 but it's
called the doubt looks like an origin
story type auto rifle faster donating
those sights it's got high caliber
that's pretty cool so I think there's
one new weapon to piece by conscious you
can tell because it's got the dead orb
or curse of Osiris logo on it shell ship
sparrow and look at that real quick if
you want
ships kind of whatever's I think all the
ships are kind of whatever is random woz
for the shells the new monarchy one has
a like lion on it so all Lions all the
time go to our boy mr. Jalal here it's
hard 84 gesture x2 tell you that there's
actually a reason to another 10 to 20
hours in this game I would say try to do
the raid layer that one was pretty good
standing around ricochet arounds it's a
viced
auto 51 mag this is probably still not
better than what you would call it
though
what's the gun called black I didn't I
think we're lacking in spry still better
unless it's like comparable in which
case and this is a dead orbit version
there's a show here's this dead orbit
ship which is kind of bleh and here's a
dead orbit Sparrow pale horse so yeah we
can go through like their ornaments are
probably the Tama stone tree Illya
started I didn't go through the future
war cult ones I guess we could go back
if we want to go do that in a second
oops sorry these aren't the only ones my
bae and they're pretty tame though in my
opinion they just add more like spray
paint to each thing that's why I think
they want our keys looks the best future
war called being close second and dead
orbits gotta gotta have the worst
ornaments this time around you guys can
see that and then we're gonna go I guess
head down to the ebz and do that faction
stuff I'm sure that doing public events
probably still netted
okay amount maybe doing some of the
other milestone stuff night falls
whatnot if anyone wants to hop on to do
some of that stuff hit me we'll get
going extension 204 hey Jen do you know
Chinese or any Asian language yes I know
I can speak a decent amount of Cantonese
not the greatest but enough to get by
can kind of understand Mandarin I
actually took a couple years of Japanese
but unfortunately when you kind of
stopped using a language you kind of
tend to forget a lot I had a really good
like I have a good memorizing type
mindset so it was pretty easy in college
but I've forgotten a lot of it I still
watch a lot of anime which helps me kind
of like um keep up with that stuff but
yeah flash points on murky which is
unfortunate but we're gonna go down to
etz and do lost sector the one lost
sector that kind of used to work was
this one but they changed it where you
can't just here I'll show you the
whining : you can't do that thing where
you do back and forth there were like
some quick farms and stuff like that but
not anymore is the heroic strike
playlist still locked out I don't know
good thing the map is
uh it seems fine I mean like I just
can't access it because I'm flying into
something but it seems fine now I don't
know if this is the best game ever I
would say regressed a little bit from d1
but yeah yeah we are farming okay so
let's let's up with ah crap I should
check the gloves so what are we gonna do
for this guy this ornaments oh we need a
complete a knife all shot going the full
new monarchy armor I don't have the I
don't have the gloves that's not fair I
guess I'm holding off doing the knife
all this week
let's see chest is just create orbs of
light while pledged and we're gonna blow
up that other armor
oh wait that's got kinetic I guess I
can't do that actually
hey do you plays on ps4 at all if you do
hit me up yeah Matt Maxwell I plan on
playing on ps4 right now because that's
where I mean we play oops
but I also play I also have a Titan on
PC I switch back and forth but I mainly
mean on mainly main on ps4 so I will try
to add you here in a second and we can
do some stuff so this used to be the run
that worked the last faction rally where
you could kind of cheese the chest thing
at the end but I don't think you can do
that anymore
you can double-check where I'm almost
positive they fix that a while ago I was
interested in this one
hex chat is coming to PC wait I thought
they already had that I really need to
change the sleep time here normally you
probably won't even spend as much time
killing as much stuff as I am but I
think you have to kill his castle
what's the victory weapons they're all
auto rifles one looks like an origin
story type one kind of looked like a
blackening type it was a vice one and
the last one I forget unfortunately I'm
sorry we'll have a gallery up on
gamespot shortly with all the weapons I
took screenshots of all that part of why
I was delayed
I wonder if trading orbs with my gun
also factors into the into the things
that's pretty that'd be pretty good
actually
so you used to be able to like do this I
get three tokens and then go in here and
you'd go up you go over here and then
you go to like a winding Cove and you're
like cool let's go back into the lost
sector and then you would like to open
the cache again and then you get more
coins but I don't oh it still works
GG boys we got that farm we got that
farm or wait I wonder if it's just
temporary if it's not though this is
hilarious and it still works in which
case we'll possibly just be running
circles the whole stream are you guys
good with that are you guys good with
that yeah we streaming a dead game today
it's it's a dying game up nope it
doesn't work it just it only worth twice
so I guess in theory so what we can try
doing I think what you can do though is
you could probably do this so we could
probably fast travel we can probably do
it twice might not even have to run that
far come back to it do it again
and you're getting six coins per
probably not the most efficient but
then we can test out how much you get
from public events - I guess since
there's one right there at winding Cove
still kind of funny that you can do it
twice though I guess oh come on tiger
knee I can't platform the day mantle no
I legit I can't I can't I can't jump
today so what happens when you get used
to BC I guess what's up Russian though
thank you sir
let's try to get oh you know it Alice I
should check there's a the generating
orbs thing I'll check that after
should be filling up a secret
whoo the chalice dungeons you want
something like that in a chalice
dungeons ultimately kind of got boring
too they were kind of fun at first and
then I was like okay so you can't repeat
him which is unfortunate so that's not
gonna work I'll just double check I'm
gonna guess that it's not gonna work
though all right so that farm didn't
work I got excited for no reason but it
looks like the resource stuff is coming
back I can hear the I heard the
fireworks already know just Glen we're
probably not even glimmer all right that
doesn't work don't do that guys yeah
let's go do the outside thing for
research watch passionately game behind
asking more silliest bird 100% got to go
new monarchy this time around because of
the ornaments they're too good
nope don't finish that one actually I
think I get credit regardless oh I'm
gonna jump down to this guy over here
and protect this one so this happens
when the factions are back and I think
since it's
[Music]
it's gonna happen on forget if it
happens on every planet
how you get button all right let's see
if we're getting that orbs thing for the
ornament because that makes having a
master work weapon all the more better
yep
at least I think so actually just not
super for a bit see if that potential is
up cuz there's at nine right now
so [ __ ] my new Marquis tokens are going
to post of course they are
did I met a person other not yet might
have to come from
no no don't kill me those 100 percent
there you go
so this is another way you can get coins
boys probably get it from killing that
thing to embed a shank over there
Orpheus must be like so fast for that
Orbison
feels bad anything different with this
rally Tay not so far other than the
ornaments Bob and there's like there's
like what one you weapon and shell and
ship and sparrow that you can earn about
it I thought there was gonna be new
armor but I was wrong it was just so
that rig is that was for when we
finished it so I guess it's like eight
total upon completing of the Supply Drop
thing
oh you know I should try clipping like
one of those fashion consumers will get
an extra faction do so we'll see how
much we get from a public event heroic
Oh to that Maxwell guy can add me on PSN
juice and gin and then I'll add you
after the fact you can just join on get
rid of this and I'll get space this game
should not go way back
warframe is good especially for a free
game what's really impressed yeah yeah
warfarin is pretty good I have I want to
get into it I just um I don't know I
heard it's a little bit hard to start
there's a lot of systems in play and I
don't know like it's it's as much as I I
think and know it's gonna be a game I
like it's part of the reason why I still
play destiny which is part of the reason
most people avoid SNe out of Sam is
because I just still have fun as I play
destiny if they all fell off they're
probably harder self we need to continue
playing destiny but for now since I do
have couple friends that still play I'm
probably going to continue
okay so the other thing you can do if
you didn't know is technically like I
could technically respawn here as a solo
player okay so you get five per heroic
used to get eight a long time ago is it
juice and gin yes it is
go get that Engram yeah story isn't that
great and the PvP is definitely not as
in-depth as halo well that's for sure
for those that came over for Kayla yep
so we got here soon enough I think yep
we did luckily got there at the end
able to put some damage in on the boss
here so we should get double credit here
hopefully to get another five more coins
so that's another way you could
potentially do it oh let's see if it
actually works
maybe not nope there you go five yeah so
if you're fast enough and lucky enough
you could rejoin the rook or a public
event and you'll probably get it that
way if people when Chad happen to know a
faster way to get thingies tell me
because yeah I definitely want to find a
faster way to get gloves from the new
our monarchy packages so I can stop
farming the packages I'm pretty much
just need the gloves that's why I'm
gonna sing for my new monarchy set on my
Titan and then I'm gonna do the
ornaments and that's pretty much all I'm
gonna do this week maybe do it on PC too
just because I think the set looks cool
but yeah I don't really have incentive
to do that on other character
unless I really want the new monarchy
stuff on my warlock to you because I
think my warlock has almost a full set
missing like one or two pieces so can't
tell if the master works stuff is
working for the armor I don't know 13%
but we did super ones I do need to use
super this to throw that other
climbing
anything now we should check the armload
see if it moved sorry
this is also to try to help you guys out
I guess 15%
it just says create or develop so
so
the law secretary definitely doesn't
work anymore though I'm just coming in
here to destroy the let's try a faster
one that I'm not checking out but yeah
some people are on though
got that new monarchy sigil that new one
best Neetu should have come out with
more PvP modes and destiny one they
remove 66 3v3 admirable Rumble might
actually come back in February with the
Crimson event and technically they added
that competitive mode the bomb mode and
they did the lives mode so that's
technically two new ones technically
what's your office account
it used to be high cuz I used to use
knell calamity but then I stopped using
it so 592 yeah I get you guys in doing a
little bit
open up
oh I wanted to help shoot that second
one but I did guy was gonna go public
event hoppin hopes will get a lot yeah I
could see that as the best one of the
fastest ways now because it's like five
times you can kind of like get ten each
time like pretty quickly that's probably
one of the fastest roads
I probably yeah that's fine I think that
Bungie still cares blacks are losing
Maki I don't think that you can say that
they don't care about their game if
they're not doing necessarily what you
want and you're a warframe then I get it
I get that you're gonna back warframe
and I don't think
why are we experiencing the fire that
guy just got melted
but the thing is the public event
hopping you can only really do that and
can only do it as a solo you can't do it
as a food which kind of takes away the
fact that like wanting to keep up I
guess
right now
the key would be just to like come back
to it assuming you can
kay Kendall saying I remember when when
she actually listened to cared about the
community side they definitely still
listen and they still care about the
community I think things that aren't
necessarily happening as fast as some
people would like them to be but that
doesn't mean that they're not listening
or try
let's do this hit them where it hurts
so yeah this is deaf this would probably
be one of the faster ways to do this
would be shocked cuz there is going to
be a potentially faster farm but this is
what I can think that for now
the old public heroic public event party
you kiddin
this was such a slow kill here that you
could potentially even wrap back around
and get five more good try
I've only very rarely gotten three like
one time where are you dropping next
want to help sure soon Larry I'm just
testing how much we can do this so low
in terms of how many times you can farm
it because you can't you can't repeat a
event in a group sadly it only works so
yeah I think it's hard yeah you can't
get fast I think getting to is pretty
consistent but trying for three is
probably pretty hard I'll get you guys
in a second though for a thingy though
I'm just gonna try to complete this etz
thing then drop in do you get more
public tokens from the mercury public
that's a good question
it's it's definitely a longer event
maybe you get ten I don't know I I can
double-check that for you too Bob we're
gonna test that here in a second
assuming there's one on Mercury to do
this guy seems to want to be trying to
do the winding Cove doohickey thing to
you
nope instead
get on that platform and I'm the ruction
I'm not a big fan of any game except
fighters there that's going to my
priming a game I play this year yeah it
looks good um I didn't get too much time
to play beta and when I did I had some
stress some of the just like the online
struggles that they had mentioned that
they're you know trying to fix which for
some people they fix it for I guess
maybe not just specifically for those
people don't think some people were able
to get on whereas I wasn't on outside of
tutorial sorry one day I wasn't able to
network at all and then the other day I
couldn't really find a match I know some
people that were able to play so happy
for them we'll be streaming that for
sure once it comes out hoping that they
do have another beta since they had
mentioned they might because of the
technical errors are going on also five
for them they just want to do more tests
[Applause]
this one there's more of those in here
so having a BBC HD Monday unfortunately
no I mean it doesn't come out one day
right it comes out to 26
I just got a token somehow they're one
of those public events happening right
now they confirmed another 24-hour beta
release on their page I will network
issues well oh sweet
thanks for that information ruction deal
wink for that at all like this send that
over I'm kind of curious to see if you
killing a high-value target to you
what is your character talking more did
we does have any voice over the line no
not worth killing high-value targets
good to know
back to holding these so you have to get
all four to get that bonus for token if
you noticed earlier that I got if you
don't do all four you're only gonna get
one per so these are kind of bad if
other people aren't talking now
help me hello
I need help secure in the payload that's
why I was gonna go do the heroic public
of it or the public event instead no we
could do both
it's always helping though oh yeah
someone is so the key would be to be
doing this while your life team is doing
the other thing and then you get that
two-for-one and you'd be getting 13
coming so this potentially
honestly get more for killing these guys
whatever now the curious thing is if you
can actually cycle back and do another
one of these fast enough like that was
you
technically you finished that right
that's it before
yep there's that extra four so that's
eight and then you go over here and you
do this guy five so 13 and then you hope
that you can do it again like right
after I trust your methods make sure to
shoot at the drill flag
Oh Unni shoot towards this area while I
was doing what that stuff over there
yeah it wasn't happening yet Bob so I
wasn't too concerned I guess but yeah I
could see what you're saying
make sure we get that event while
covering the other supply thing
quaint destiny - made me rhesus cry the
wild Oh interesting
well I heard while got a lot better with
the latest updates and then that all of
Azeroth comes out this year right so I
could see why a lot of people could use
well maybe not a lot but people would be
going back to Wow Stella saw a game it's
just not as big as it used to be I don't
know if the world is ready for any I
know
I don't know if that's the way anymore
body melts and so fast
so we got to make sure we got the five
tokens and then really come on it
already happened and I'm blind so now
you know you leave and you hope pray
what's the flashpoint this week it's
mercury and we were too slow I guess or
sometimes you could try joining again
basically you're just trying to re
instance what's up I created read public
event hopping comments and three two one
see
nope guess there just wasn't a slow one
or someone didn't trigger one somewhere
else here let's oh shoot oh let's go
finish this milestone because you get I
think you want to do the milestone every
day because I want to say it's like 20
coins we're not gonna risk it any more
just gonna do better platforming go
check out more crew see if the high
values give you tokens alright let me
finish this etz milestone and then we'll
go check it out maybe on my way there
I'll add these people
there
my values give you one planetary token
that's it
that sucks I was just there says no
nurses all right thanks Dan
I honestly think the way is like if you
can get one of those little supply
thingies and then also at the same time
like a public event right next to it
that's probably your best bet if you
have enough people that just kind of
like cycle through both but those events
kind of just happen
Oh melting myself yeah oh sorry so it's
not 20 is 15
you have 15 for the milestone you guys
are curious which is unfortunate because
like you would think that since it's a
daily you should just be able to get 20
because then that's like one usually
enough for one package let me go full
camera really quick so I can add these
folks
Quest's guessing gesture in the night
mad mix possibly this guy possibly this
guy possibly this guy I'm just going to
assuming that anyone in the last 20
minutes is probably all right so I added
a bunch of people oops
good luck to this guy what's the best
type of armor that's hard to say it
depends on what you want to do with your
character mobility is doesn't really
actually add that much you want it a
little bit for PvP but it doesn't really
add that much to PvE
I'll have to double-check Bob on the
double-crosser did you see the fighters
links I posted if it's not on its
official US Twitter they haven't decided
on x but confirmed another 24-hour beta
all right sweet I will tell the News
team assemble
don't kill anything yet
his rigs killed everything rip in
everything please drop a ship of some
sort
fire the GameSpot goodbye do they still
think they can outrun us
and Orpheus probably gets this [ __ ] done
the fastest or for that ornament thingy
our prerequisite or just and super is
most likely because I'm probably still
like pretty in the weeds here with what
I need to do here yeah 31% of rip that
guys buy a grand old time I just you
know make sure I killed what just stuff
with my secret what's up Andrew Fidel
what's up Jim how I'm doing pretty good
I hope you're doing alright see you
what's the hand cannon you're using
forwards as Dylan Smith better Devils
address
got it closer I did all that purple ammo
come on we need more stuff to kill
kill my really
oh wait
oh come on
this guy's just rig spamming all day
what's up BB king
yeah whoever I added you proofreader
join I've added a bunch of people I try
to cycle through
take those orbs so I can keep super into
yeah if anyone eyes that that joint is
Nightstalker with the singing I think
that's actually legit for this for
farming part of it let's have Lars Sura
kill line
what's up am bill one gaming aka Ryan
Schubert in the office
I mean looking actually know we can
you kill the captain at least he's worth
more worms so if you don't pick it up
for a while comb raising a lot of stuff
what's up Beauty game alright we are
gonna go to the sludge Larry go to the
sludge rip my bubble buddy's sunbreaker
for life yeah I'm trying
oh and we joined in wall an event was
happening sure
yeah I'm trying to go some breaker just
because I've been playing so much
striker tighten that it's like I feel
like you got to mix it up
kind of wish defender was better
Sentinel tiny but it's still whoa that
guy was flying we do it all word clip
oh hello
oh don't explode somebody is hitting
hopefully our boys Lars and didi King
aren't gonna get here in time for the
turning in these tokens yeah they should
get the bonus yeah so yeah I think your
best bet is just going to do some of the
supply drops while doing public events
and we still there's some type of farm
that gets exposed eventually it happens
how do you play how do you play in the
college library are you just using one
of the monitors at the library for a
decimal while you wait for your buddies
to get off the night off I would say if
you can hold off do the nightfall after
you have a full set Armour so you make
sure they get that one perk or the one
prereq for the ornament there's like I'm
missing gloves I'm hoping again love
today before I do the night class
[Music]
I haven't done an iPhone once I still do
him last week this breed was last week's
funny
lastly this prison a couple weeks before
that was fun when it was touring I'm
kind of salty about that one week there
where they finally had that mercury
strike and apparently if you did the
prestige version there was a new emblem
but then because of a like a weird bug
with a clan Engram this thing they
killed it and then you couldn't get the
emblem a circle because they switched it
back to there's an old nightfall
text what
of course it's back where we were
we're gonna blow
no it's presently no one died now if
there you go face to die to that all the
time
why bother with I value target just
because there's no reason to kill them
it's just because no one in my clan is
still playing yeah make sense i lfg eat
a couple of net balls it's usually fine
unless it's like actually a hard one no
no nightfall should be that bad though
that are harder now
alright boys we are going see you guys
whining Co go go go it'sit's active
right now winding Co I actually need to
get all the armor now yeah that's the
tough part JK j g f king assuming you're
trying to get that new monarchy set i
was fortunate enough that last time i
mostly went anyone our key ID sadly just
didn't get a pair of gloves so hoping to
get that this time around obviously and
then I'm pretty much done for the week
I'm less like I said I want to barley
ornaments and the one piece I'm missing
name
lmao you saw y'all still playing this
ish yes like I said is weekly update
more reason than any other week to come
back next week's gonna be another dead
week though because there's nothing
until the 30th Brian banner but then
there's gonna be a masterwork
arm wear and some other updates coming
on that 30th which we'll check out
obviously if I won't do anything too
much next week because there isn't much
happening in destiny to next week
I don't like the time stuff some people
we're making the argument that those
events should be like these events
should be like two weeks instead of one
week which I could see happening may be
dawning is like what three weeks
your stream is on big TV I'm on one
piece of my controller sick you don't
like keyboard/mouse uh ninny
23 actually find a keyboard mouse pretty
good on PC I guess that destiny on PC
just need to UM pcs a lot faster than on
Tom I just don't most of my friends just
never switched over to PC because that's
where
that still plays tacos
this game is on ps4 guess we go to Hades
Guardian what we can try to is a we
tried doing heroic strike and see how
many coins you get out of that
I'm reading a skiff with glimmer mining
equipment aboard Noddy and mining
equipment is great can I hate the mining
one you think I liked it the most and it
was like really slow but now I think
it's really slow after this we're gonna
do a
I do a what you call it I just realized
didi King that level Tony around before
make me think expansion
I did a heroic I got seven tokens deck
doctor plane that doesn't seem worth it
them to be honest because every heroic
public event is five and you can
obviously do her of public events faster
than you can and heroic strike obviously
now you're gonna do your three weeks
give or take toward the milestone but
yeah that doesn't seem worth it at all
no I do about my girlfriend brick
someone like he's raging on my PC or is
it was she raging it obviously not a new
playing some game seriously game she's
playing I positive age there are some
rage inducing games out there obviously
I think he killed it ready fill them
selfish Orca flow is actually like
really good for public events because
you're generally gonna get a lot of
purple ammo I don't think my war clip is
3:35 though nope I'm a scrub
you can do three are our public events
at least in the time we've won hopes
right yeah sorry
maybe you get more if you solo and get
like the double
I'll let you know if I get more than
seven we're doing mile seven at the
moment yeah cool thanks dr. flame don't
forget a go show that gives you the
chance to get an additional token yeah I
was thinking about that I just have no
like does anyone know if that's actually
working I guess I should the sagir is
not do that
I thought the gears did that no it
doesn't know yeah increased chance
increase blue mare and chance to obtain
an additional 400 on Mercury they're
just one for faction
I gotta check my other go shelter oh
damn I died I'm only level 20 he cannot
join
oh sorry max well currently the party's
full but I'll try to get you in
boom a firework
well was that Randall the vandal
yeah I guess my sagir shelving adds more
chance on mercury
help
Wow my aim not good oh sweet
all right so DB Kings in the plan we
should PvP to to get our planning RAM
for the lead for that kind of curious
how many you get from a crucible match
why not that much I would assume like
five to seven it works when doing the
catch each one gives an excuse
where are you getting a cash that gives
you a coin firetrap Miguel yeah I'm
using the fireteam with elements that
was five don't eat it on this character
I'm gonna try going and doing a PvP
match boys actually I could get a fourth
person in if they want a PvP yes go to
orbit in that maybe Maxwell can join
Maxwell you probably get this message
late but I'll sit in orbit for like a
thirty seconds for you to join and see
if you see you have any we get from
crucible I'm guessing we're only getting
at about seven whoa what is this track
tracks your pledges see me monarchy oh
how many times I pledged
unless they're talking about lost sector
caches I was getting three when I turned
them in earlier all right there's max
all right cool I would do PvP for a
little bit got some people in now sadly
PvP is only for people so but that's the
most we're gonna get uh-oh not everyone
has curse of Osiris that's okay because
we can still do normal PvP can you get
coins on other planets other than need
easy yes you should be able to unlike
any planet I would assume that because
the Supply Drop should probably happen
on every planet and you can get them
from any heroic public event so you know
obviously if you don't see any on the e
DZ you're definitely gonna want ahead -
you know like mercury this week is like
at least the milestone nothing going on
here though apparently high-value
targets on Mercury aren't really given
much given tolling so you could probably
do it here like any public events gonna
get you five but I guess the dream
scenario is if you're solo you want to
try to get multiple heroic public events
if you can do them like within getting
to this the second of the same one fast
enough and then it's nice if you have
like a Supply Drop that's nearby because
you can get eight from that like four
from holding each one and then another
four for completing all four let's try
your best bet having that plus like a
heroic or that in a public event nearby
just have like your team do you know
like have half your team go there and
then like another just doing the public
event or something because that would be
thirteen at one time if you could do
both of those at the same time
don't yeah so I could try equipping a
ghost shell maybe for crucible so chance
to obtain additional faction consumables
in the crucible it's a chance so we'll
just try adding that and seeing if I
would assume it's about seven for
finishing a crucible match but we'll see
it was a bi chat confirmed this seven
for a heroic strike there's a fireteam
medallion help you get more faction
tokens I doubt it control dr. flame I
doubt it
unless people are not getting getting
like less than five or whatever is the
boons don't okay that's good to know
fine control
they're going straight to see looks like
they're going to see
oh my god I just whipped so hard on that
good name yeah it's funny I haven't
played too much solar Titan on PvP as I
may have
UKaid the lead
took the lead
you gave the lead I love it
oh that ain't beer which is bad don't be
lost
it's a power play get those homes back
you captured zone a
mr. wall
speak to me my Asian brother what's up
got pilk how are you Neha what check out
I'm working in a second I just want to
get some PvP in because oh lordy because
we have a couple of viewers I wanted to
play and this is easiest way to kinda
get more people on crap trying to also
get rid the clan thing done but
[Music]
don't
zone a capture zone advantages
and joke that one should have the other
barricade on I know but nice worth o
players left a team know while ours hang
hands that only feel better on PC to
console well if you want it to PvP and I
added you you can definitely join
my went from 307 to 335 with 12 jarocho
yeah that's pretty good that's a lot of
luck too though let's be real which the
other factor has a very good I'm not
sure I didn't actually look at the guns
the with the new monarchy one had a high
caliber oh my lord I'm dead I was
shooting in the Nova bomb that's suck
that cassette me tough
Lari the Hedgehog what happened Larry
don't advantage is yours
don't see
right
rip now it was something like this
technician thank you for that appreciate
it I have to go Opie strike now see me
Palpatine
is then
you know pickup neuroses for this next
game or something
Oh
ten seconds
Challenge I don't know how many coins it
was because I couldn't see we have 78
now so I just had to play another game I
guess to find out so 78 remember 78 the
number 78 will go based off that so it
looks like a solid 7 each one did you
guys actually see oh no her Oaks okay so
seven for her Oaks I got to see I I I
had too many things pop on the screen
there so we have 78 coins now I written
that down just to make sure I'm gonna
play one more PvP to hope that we just
win here I'm gonna get try to get a
fourth nope nope he's try to get fourth
in here
seventy-eight yeah I don't know we
didn't even play that much to be honest
oh actually no that's not true we played
about an hour give or take see if he
takes that invite
awkward repping and wearing a dead orbit
chest but uh repping me want our key I
would wrap a new monarchy but uh it's
not from next level yet 48 percent for
orbs got pilk
just let me join you super 31% oh wait
you gotta get supers on the e DZ I guess
you want to farm easy then for ya
and I don't have the glow so I can tell
you and that's helm is uh knife all got
pilk you can add me juice yeah you can
see it there juice and gin if you add me
I can add you as a friend real quick I
am playing just on a regular piece where
I know go full camera real quick let me
see if I can get
[Music]
oh wait you might just join sorry got
poked I'll get you in I'll try to get
you in the next game but he said in the
friend request too though because that
hasn't gone through yet
trying to win this for the clan Mohamed
Salah I literally stopped for three
minutes I feel like people on the
internet have more a DD nowadays maybe
it's just our generation and maybe it's
like I don't know
everyone needs screen time now like I
have to be on your phone and stuff yeah
we should you match a striker your armor
looks awesome oh I was pretty good I'm
missing the chest from the raid trying
to look like a shredder from the Ninja
Turtles but I'm missing the chest
so hopefully this week when I do the
raid layer with my friends and finish
the set and that'll be done with the
raid lair kind of more or less
[Music]
well Gigi for me I only play on PC so no
cross plate for me next time got pill I
also play on PCs so I'll send the friend
request and I'll be down to Joy and when
you know swap oh thanks dr. flame yeah I
mean we still kind of do weekly destiny
streams those are starting to taper off
just because there's less stuff in the
game but I'll definitely be back for
that iron banner patch so definitely be
looking for people to iron banner with
so feel free to send me an invite and
I'll try to get different viewers in for
the iron banner day and of course thank
you guys all for tuning in for you guys
that don't know we're streaming every
day at 11 a.m. except currently
Wednesday the lobby is on hiatus for a
little bit so we'll be throwing in some
streams here and there every Wednesday
but not always consistently but
definitely Monday Tuesday Thursday
Friday as long as it's not a holiday
I'll hop out after this match for
viewers to play it sounds good neurosis
I'm probably gonna play with maybe one
turn one matches after I just wanted to
see how many coins we're getting per
match I want to say it's 7 I just didn't
actually do the math before we started
this oh this is a good side please
everyone on my team if you can hear me
um through the stream just don't take
see stay at a and B and we can camp aim
to you for like the long haul
there's like nothing they can do about
it unless they can take a from us to
then take you well okay maybe they'll
get B because I'm the only one left
alive right but yeah see like look at
how hard it is they either got a swing
around over there or to the right to get
B and my whole team spawned again so
it's like we're flying unless we get
completely out Slade which is also very
possible I suppose I just have to equip
a scout and my primary is that a better
Devils because we're just getting out
ranged Oh someone's here
Oh
quickly change to scouts midnight should
be pretty solid here on this map
nice don't just try to push me off the
heavy
so I'm here at sting oh I didn't realize
I was on my midnight whoops
hope you win this round I hope that to
you how did you get DC Larry
oh my god they're so low I don't know
why they had
I shouldn't have peeked
using progeny is cool using one of the
vex weapons yeah Dan's going yolo
swaggins doing what i potentially said
not to do which is i guess okay
hopefully we don't get this stolen
then please some type of Russian oh you
got DC it alright I'll try I'll get you
back in this stupid that's the most
donate you got we don't really take
donations the only time we ever took
donations was for extra life our charity
stream that goes proceeds goes to the
children and we raised about 20,000 I
think no solo everyone she's getting
clean up kills usually my job hello from
the USA oh damn it what raids happening
look a scout rifle
I'm gonna be able to make this play hope
so three minutes left where are you
going buddy dominating the field okay
I'm not gonna press my advantage too
much don't want to overextend and give
them a chance to spawn somewhere we
don't want them to you you gotta pretty
much lock it down right now as it should
be I don't think you want to be there
buddy okay
Oh what the melee yes
I traded
that's fine are you being the meze bro
no I'm Chinese that's what I'm playing
with you all thanks Larry
you guys see you call that a strimm
Oh burning one well finally lost be
blanks one minute
that's bad
30 seconds remain
he's still over there as being greedy I
want to kill clip off the positive
outlook I don't even remember which
scout purpose is let's all team shot him
there's so much stuff like we go look at
the coin stack in a second ridiculous
who did I say we needed to get in here
at the end cuz we got a couple of spots
to fill alright so we had 78 oh it's
only five that's actually quite awful
so five for crucible seven for so five
for crucible let me back out of PvP
yep later uh dan thanks for hopping in
you get seven for heroic strike you get
five for a heroic public event I think I
got three for a loss sector cash so what
else was there oh and then you get eight
for finishing the the Supply Drop thing
who's I'm missing Larry you can join
back if you need to
nice one says rod mr. prime Thank You
Rodimus we did what we needed to which
has held those two points and locked it
down essentially Larry if you get back
in I'll do one more PvP but that's kind
of about it we probably got a wrap of
the stream otherwise I got to go into
the tower to try to purchase some gloves
but maybe Larry's taking off though I
don't know cuz he said it was fun
playing with you I don't know we're
gonna go to the tower he can try joining
up Oh Mad Max I'm probably calling in a
stream Mad Max so I'm gonna have to boot
you from the party I apologize but I
can't go to the tower with you in the
group I do not play for at night
unfortunately Maxwell doing do Neal
which is Mad Max there Larry if you want
to we can do one more PvP but that'll
I'm gonna go at our first try to get
these gloves so we can start working on
the actually it should already be
working on the what we need for the
ornament
fifty percent it's gonna take a take a
hot minute probably really fast like I
said for man their mobility garbage
supers got to do it on the easy
you're in okay
how are you in are you just gonna end up
in my tower guess so
we'll see if art and Jesus loves us or
not I guess it probably won't but
upgrade your super what do you mean it's
already upgraded
see upgraded could use this one well
like this one war four double grenade
well see how many coins we have in the
bank - because I think a lot of them
we're going there so you might have
enough to buy like five packages maybe I
think five is what you need for one of
the requirements for the order rate
though I have 14 not terrible do we have
enough for a hundred aha we're three
short
just revive four packages feels bad
can't do math
which vaccine is the best for me
personally this time around sir Luke's
are I'm going new monarchy just for the
armor ornaments because I think they
look the best but I haven't checked all
three rifles to see which auto rifle is
the best I wouldn't be shocked if it's
like you want our future work all just
to kind of mix things up because the
future work halt one had high caliber
whereas this one just has like that old
cero's perk which is like more damage at
the end of the magazine it's got
ricochet appended and yeah so I think
that the best auto rifle is probably the
future work all one patrols completed oh
you got finished 15 patrols on it easy
for the gloves all right good luck to us
20 coins sometimes these can be full max
level engrams if you just wait to change
you today but whatever all right we got
the helm which is useless the gloves all
right we got the gloves second try
either the dupe system thing is back in
or we just got lucky
I'll take it not gonna complain legit
pretty good stuff do I have a 3:30 I
could burn feels bad and whatever put it
through twenty nine to it alright so we
got the full set now not 3:25 sadly or
335 but uh pretty close I mean if we
just add some mods I'm sure you know
would be again then we be getting there
and a decent I don't have any
that's what just added connect more to
it that's fine whatever
those are kind of hard to come by though
for me sure and solar kind of perk to
dad man whatever alright so yeah there's
my full name on our key set I look like
a clown right now but hey it worked out
oh good to see you
cool coming to the tower now it says
Larry alright Larry we're gonna go do
that one PvP match cuz I said I would um
and max if you want to join back on us
you can do that too
oh the titan Mart what about it I have
the two oh right
okay that's fair Bob you're correct
I I do have it though oh [ __ ] are over
3:30 though I'll just burn the Terra
[ __ ] one into it can't I can't blow
up my raid raid layer one I guess sure
whatever I have more Brazil I can just
take a shitload of damage I guess thank
you Bob
there you go there's your coronation
mark we need the frickin ornament for it
though real bad I can't believe I'm
repping you honor you go man it feels
bad I've been dead orbit since destiny
won
I missed those exotic the Titan Mark the
exotic one that was pretty cool that
took some work getting to you alright
Mad Max if you want to get back in I'm
gonna give you like a hot second I can
just invite you from the roster and it
might be faster except you aren't on
I'm playing for now I'll play later okay
we going in then we're just going in
what's up MBA young boy and ba yan boy
oh we can play a Cyrus now right now who
doesn't
oh no Cyrus I think DD King doesn't know
no Cyrus why I'm still FWC even though
white for some reason this time even
though they are white yeah I actually
like it that's like the one thing for me
that makes me want to do a future war
cult character so maybe my hunter will
go future work all because she already
is future Walker what a war called
all right last match coming in now
thanks to the guys and gals that joined
us in PvP and like just running about
doing some fun stuff appreciate it
we will be back for sure in two weeks
when iron banner is out so I'll
definitely try to pick some of you guys
up to do that IB stuff should be fun
kind of curious how they're gonna do the
PvP if it'll be one mode or like one of
those rotating roulette modes hoping for
Roulettes
pink Necromorph saying Dead game it's
dying sensible people don't own a cyrus
that's that's fair fox bait Osiris is
not a very good deal see in my opinion
that's not you Larry it's ydd King I
could tell you all know Cyrus because
you have the that one emblem for
[Music]
completing the loss for stuff looking
forward to Monster Hunter beta Metal
Gear survive beta later this week
looking forward to that one more hour of
DBZ fighters whenever they do it which
would be cool let's see where is it
thanks to all that interested and we've
decided to do another round 24 period
clash
clashing it okay I shipped a thank you
party of none I hate this map just fine
I would say PvP is probably not the way
to farm coins though for anyone that's
curious a nice rip on my save me shoot
is larry gonna DC again he's stuff like
okay how did that even hit us
real talk we're not healing I have skull
boy oh I don't have a skull for Don
by getting life back
feel like I should have asked out on him
then that guy has a [ __ ] fusion rifle
I can nail is about to get a double oh
we're playing a three stack all right
that's their sort of only down nine
what's with the server's being offline
what we talk about future work all are
in Newmarket I'm gonna monarchy panda
Panda I go with public events yep for
sure dr. flame I agree I think public
events is gonna be the fastest until
someone finds some crazy efficient
farming route which the community always
does some type of exploit you type
things crazy
using that trick in old fashioned from
that far away however you're just so
good from anywhere
I'm going you monarchy though because
the the ornaments just looks so damn
good this time around I get those wines
only five minutes left
I'll use my fists because I'm a Titan oh
it's a rocket run not good that like
surrounded uh it was like we were in the
house and then we were getting raided by
like the SWAT team and they had every
access point covered and yet I was dumb
enough to run into the house dead body
oh come on and dad their dad's mourning
for the updated
that's what we're talking Helen bring in
smoke right now and that's a Golden Gun
yeah feels the best when you spawn into
someone that happenings too super but he
might have just read this situation
right in you or worse morning that's
also possible oh cool
take that jerk at least we're gonna lose
fast I guess there's there's at least
bad sometimes losing fast is as good as
a you know winning because we're still
getting coins
oh shoot how many coins
no three minutes left
I just want to run away from colony
grenades can you guys let me have that I
have every play more on PC or ps4 I mean
mainly ps4 just because it's like I
swear my break I'm like well I mean I've
been enjoying PC like in there like in
between well let me at least get my
super off before the end of this match
No
please no no for the rest of them at
least let me have this oh wow we got two
tokens so you only have the only a five
if you win ripp okay good to know just
do public events hundred percent for
right now just do public events and do
those supply drop things
woohoo point two eight three no way look
at that it's the worst I've done in a
while thank you guys all for tuning in
appreciate it appreciate the people that
join in and play it hope you had some
fun and until next time we'll be back on
when I mean back tomorrow actually at 11
a.m.
possibly looking at the vision 1.8
Update since a lot of people last time
when I was streaming destiny was telling
we're telling me to check that out
so we might do that Thursday for sure
we're doing metal I think well shouldn't
say for sure for sure I got double check
the time but I'm pretty sure we're gonna
be able to Metal Gear survival on
Thursday and then we're gonna do Monster
Hunters final beta before release on
Friday so until then see you guys next
time thank you so much
[Music]
[Music]
you